here with reaction ranking member of the
house in telemedicine Devin Nunez and
the author of which on Fox News legal
analyst Greg Jarrett we already know
that the process is flawed because at
the end of the day congressman is it
true or not true Adam Schiff who's
compromised in this case he gets to deny
the witnesses you call he gets to make
the final decision on everything doesn't
he so there really is no there are no
rights by for the ranking members of the
President and his attorneys well as you
know nobody likes to disagree with Rush
Limbaugh but I think in this case Rush
Limbaugh only has it about half right at
least during the Cavanaugh hearings the
Republicans have the ability to bring up
people who were supporting Cavanaugh we
don't even have that so Adam Schiff and
his team whoever met with the
whistleblower we've had no access to the
whistleblower number two we want to know
what was the DNC's involvement and the
Clinton campaign is involvement in
Ukraine and why did the Ukrainians
interfere in our election we also have
out there the situation with hunter
Biden how did he get eighty some
thousand dollars a month these are just
basic questions that we deserve to have
the answer to before any of this circus
is set to begin on Wednesday we should
have those answers now you have a list
of people including Adam Schiff the
whistleblower nellie or hunter Biden Joe
Biden will any of your witnesses be
allowed to testify yeah that as of right
now we have none of our witnesses right
so I mean look we even put on ambassador
Volker
okay this was these this guy was the
Democrats first witness came in didn't
go very well for them you've all seen
the transcripts he came in voluntarily
the transcripts are out why on earth
would Volcker not be there he was the
special envoy to Ukraine we're having
the top people at the State Department
who handled Ukraine and now the acting
ambassador that it's that's coming in on
Wednesday why would you not have Volcker
on the same panel why would you not give
the Republicans a witness so as of right
now we have no witnesses and we have no
knowledge of the foundation of this case
and of this these accusations
but if you know fundamentally like
everything else and you outline it this
in both your books
Craig Jarek everything boomerangs back
the only Russian interference we know it
was the dossier I mean it's a little
ironic now Ukraine election interference
I thought that wouldn't matter that's
the Democrats and the only quid pro quo
is hunter Biden you get the billion if
you fire the guy investigating my son
you don't get the billion otherwise if
this were an equitable process both
sides they would be able to call their
own witnesses but Adam Schiff won't
allow it he can only and will only allow
witnesses that he likes reminds me of
the old Henry Ford quote any customer
can have a car painted any color as long
as it's black look at the first two
witnesses that will be called on
Wednesday bill Taylor and George Kent
they admit they have no direct knowledge
of a quid pro quo instead they heard it
from a guy who heard it from a guy who
heard it from an original guy and in
both cases its diplomat
Gordon Sunland sunland admits he has no
direct knowledge of a quid pro quo
instead he testified he presumed it so
this is opinion built on hearsay
constructed on speculation and
conjecture now the Senate congressman
Nunez they would have the ability to
call all of these witnesses Lindsey
Graham said and he that this is dead on
arrival without the whistleblower and he
wants hunter Biden to testify tell us
what the Senate can do and what would
you recommend they do well let's see how
this goes this week my guess is it's
going to be a complete circus we're not
going to get any of our witnesses the
mainstream media is going to say how
damaging it is to the president that's
just going to be the storyline but the
fact of the matter is if you actually
read these transcripts and Gregg Jarrett
was just going through them Byron York
has a piece out tonight talking about
venneman their star witness these
transcripts as we were saying when the
Democrats were slowly leaking these out
to the friends and the media that that's
what we've been doing for the last six
weeks but now that the transcripts are
out they're devastating to the Democrat
so let's see where it goes but at the
end of the day the Senate should be
calling all these people in as soon as
possible okay hope the Senate's
listening they add they've got to do
their job now